we're talking about it in part because
nature
news published a piece this week
headlined toxic workplaces are biggest
reason women leave
Academia so far I have shared with you
various little bits and pieces from the
paper that that headline is based on and
what I find is um there's not that much
difference in the leaving by sex but
even when there's no difference in in
terms of um whether men or women are
leaving more there's some differences in
what they report about why they left and
uh men are more likely to say I left for
professional reasons and women are more
likely early in career um more likely to
say work life balance which is something
we've all heard a lot about it and and
make some sense but late in career um
it's this third thing that no one was
talking about until now which is um work
environment work climate so
uh I went to the supplemental
material uh which hold on did I get to
the end yeah um I went to the
supplemental material here uh their
survey items that they actually asked
people actually I'll scroll so you can't
see so under professional
stress um you know is that you maybe had
to produce too many papers get funding
um your institution wanted you to work
on particular topics you weren't
recognized your salary wasn't good
enough you weren't getting uh your work
accepted uh you didn't feel like your
department was providing administrative
support all of those make sense and
aren't based on
feels right um you know poor
administrative support I could see how
you your feels could be a part of that
but there's also just like you know are
there enough support staff um to do the
kind of work that needs to be done or
are you left doing things that you were
told when you were hired for instance
you wouldn't have to do for
yourself right work life stress um
associated with balancing work in life
caring
responsibilities um you know you have
the two- body problem where maybe you
know you're both in fields that are
somewhat rarified and they need to move
and you're like I I got to move too uh
lack of time for hobbies and interests
um amount of time you have to work lack
of leave time um and then personal
issues so all of those make sense and
again some of them are um subjective for
sure but you can point to them and say
you know what I just I just wanted more
time to Surf right I just wanted more
time to actually spend time with my kids
or to you know to to think about whether
or not this is what I want to be doing
because it looks to me like if I keep
doing this forever I'm going to wake up
in 30 years and not have done anything
else right professional stress work life
stress and then climate stress the one
that we are told um that is the big
difference where women are more likely
to report these things than men the
basis again before I show you the basis
for which that nature news article said
it's workplace toxicity that's why women
leave we
have dysfunctional departmental culture
or leadership Dell yeah pretty much all
of them just that's Academia for you
feeling the new need to prove myself
feeling that people like me don't belong
or fit in my department wait no sorry
or fit in my department feeling that
people like me don't belong or fit in my
institution feeling that people like me
don't belong or fit in my academic field
harassment discrimination how
competitive Academia is constant
criticism comparisons
rejections
so the three of those that I have not
highlighted dysfunctional departmental
culture harassment and discrimination
are plausibly not entirely subjective
certainly sometimes they are not
entirely
subjective the rest of these the basis
for which we have a nature news headline
claiming that workplace toxicity is why
women leave Academia because women are
more likely to answer yes to I feel that
people like me don't belong here and
it's just so competitive
this is such insanity this is playing
into such crazy regressive stereotypical
female tropes about how women behave and
what they're willing to do to get their
way and like and nature news is buying
into it this research is garbage this
survey was garbage and they had under
professional stress and work life stress
a number of things that are
real and in this third category almost
nothing here is based on anything but I
just don't feel like this is the thing
for me furthermore these are leading
questions how many people are going to
say well yeah actually I I didn't really
feel like I belonged now that you put it
that way yeah that is why I
left well and the problem is that um the
work if you can call it work the This
research yeah yeah like all this stuff
is designed to create a pretext for
remedies that are desired and the point
is this becomes
increasingly a welfare program where
people create scholarship for
which they feel entitled to be paid
entitled to get benefits so they are
parasites on the University system on
society and what they are producing as a
result of their parasitism is pretext
for further parasitism yes and this is
this is Midway in there it's a jobs
program it's a it is a make work program
it's not even a jobs program because
they're going to get
benefits they have a nominal job but it
is a job that does not need to be done
fact civilization be better off if it
weren't right um well it's you know it's
not like the WPA where a bunch of things
need to be work you don't necessarily
get paid for for I I think we're saying
the same thing we just have different
connotations for what these terms mean
for me a job Rogan's like oh I just need
to figure out a pretext for getting paid
like well this is it y but the idea you
know you could twiddle your thumbs for a
salary that you didn't deserve and in
fact you know people in the tech sector
talk about the huge number of people who
don't do anything and you know people
talk about the fact that Elon Musk fired
a huge fraction of the staff and Twitter
got better not worse um so apparently
they weren't doing anything productive
so there's not doing anything productive
and then there is doing something
destructive in the very system that is
paying you to do that work right you are
a paid sabator yep and um you know I
must tell you my my reaction overall
is this system is so broken to begin
with it's scientifically broken before
you even get to the fields that don't
really exist and are attacking science
and the scientists aren't even ready to
defend themselves and say no I'm sorry
stop messing around with sex we actually
understand this and you're not allowed
from some other field to you know lob
hand grenades in actually there are two
Sexes we we know how to define them we
know a lot about what they mean and um
you know you can go have your little
discussion elsewhere but you're not
going to get us to change what we say to
students about whether there are two
Sexes there are right that's what they
should be saying but they don't so the
scientists are pitiful yes because they
won't stand up for themselves they're
too um cowardly to just simply even
stick up for the truth yep and the sabur
fields are on the March and taking over
the thing and the real question is um
look I'm sorry we do need a University
system but we don't have one and
pretending that it is one doesn't help
and decid pretending that you could
rescue this one Rescue It really all
these cowards you're going to free them
from something and they're going to go
back to work I don't think so I don't
even think they remember what work is I
mean this is this is you and I have said
this over and over again but people
often um say when you know various
projects about you know creating a new
University oh but you know is there
going to be demand it's like oh there's
demand there will be so many students in
Act ual functioning University will
there be sufficient faculty yeah that is
what we are going to have a dir of and
yeah we need a lot more students and we
need faculty but we're going to have a
harder time getting a functioning
University filled with actually
competent and courageous faculty because
we've ruined a whole generation of
faculty and yes we're in the process of
ruining a whole generation of of college
AE students as well and they're ruined
in a different way and in some ways more
completely but the faculty once they're
in their little foms of their classrooms
get to completely destroy people and
they're doing it well this is a classic
it's actually worse than that because
the reason that there are not enough
people to staff a proper University
where you to start one is not that those
people don't exist it's that if you
assume that an academic has an academic
degree then you're taking people all of
whom have been lobotomized by the
process that trained them there are lots
of smart people who could do a bang-up
job of educating people but how would
you who are you going to hire to figure
out who they are right because the fact
is they don't have degrees they did
other things they actually you know they
in large measure were driven out by the
idiocy of the system as it stands and
they went and did something else some of
them have no degree at all yeah but the
accreditation process says uh you risk
losing your accreditation if you've got
non-terminally degreed people teaching
your classes I remember actually at
Evergreen you wanted to teach with a
friend of ours uh it was brilliant and
it was going to an amazing program but
he doesn't you know he just had a
bachelor's degree and uh you know the
admin powers that be are like you can't
we we can't do this like even though
this would be one of the most
extraordinary programs that has ever
been taught NOP nope certainly can't
nope right so you know the it's a system
that is in a death spiral because the
correct move is actually forbidden which
is to figure out who's actually still
smart right you are you are required to
search a landscape of people who
um were foolish enough to continue to
sign up the rules in an era of uh
increasing sophistry
yeah
um this is just more sophistry but I'm
going to share one more piece of soft
stre from the same paper before we move
on just the very next page here this was
um you were you were showing um you were
shown table S9 from the supplemental
material just now and if I just scroll
down one more page this is 63 pages of
supplemental material survey data
cleaning they did a number of data
cleaning choices made a number of data
cleaning choices including about
gender three out of the 6570 men in our
survey indicated they are transgender
men one out of the 3,480 women in our
women and one of the women in our survey
indicated they are women and
nonbinary while these five individuals
used the prefer to self-describe box in
order to describe their gender we also
included them in the binary gender
categories that they mention mentioned
in their
descriptions including participants who
self-reported these additional aspects
of their gender identities into men and
women categories allows us to respect
their status as men and
women which these numbers are tiny right
but that nullifies anything else that
they have done right right there the
point is the fact that the numbers are
tiny means it probably didn't change
things much but they do not say in light
of you know the right thing to do would
be to exclude them but of course that
would be transphobic or whatever um so
the fact that they include them says
that they are more committed to um
saluting the correct flag than they are
to actually discovering anything and you
know this respecting their status as men
and women which they're not so wait a
second this I mean they're one of them
but they're not the one they say they
are if you go back to the thing that I
was saying about you start renaming
stuff and you make it impossible to
actually reconstruct history or to track
a particular creature you know because
now they have a name that nobody can say
because somebody might feel hurt about
it so you can't figure out the
scholarship on that creature before the
name change y y y right um this the idea
that we are going to include you under
the name under the gender that you self
describe means that we are no longer
going to be able to figure out anything
about sex differences this is a
self-fulfilling prophecy 100% and Y um
so the point is it's like I bet all the
people who identify as the sex that they
are not were more likely to say oh it's
a had a toxic work environment right
yeah um but let's put it this way
they're wielding an argument right about
sex not being a thing right right and
then they're going to make sex not a
thing at the level of the data right and
then they're going to say see it's in
the data right no difference between men
and women and that's who looks at
supplemental material 63 pages of
supplemental materials who looks there
right so anyway the point is it's
another attack on our ability to
understand even what what's true right
never mind whether it's fair let's just
figure out what's true and then we can
talk about whether it's fair but you're
not even be able to know true first yeah
true would be first has that this is
this is the proof that once again um the
purpose of the exercise is not the one
that we all think academics has the
sabur have fli the purpose right right
the purpose is to advance a particular
story and to the extent that the truth
gets in the way there going to disrupt
our ability to even know what it
[Music]
is